no lograrán aislar a rusia citando el
programa espacial soviético como una
muestra de éxito de moscú en las
dificultades el presidente vladimir
putin acompañado de su homólogo
bielorruso alexander lukachenko aseguró
que su país no volverá a depender de
occidente desde el cosmódromo vostochni
en el lejano oriente ruso
si no tenemos intención de estar
aislados es imposible aislar severamente
a alguien en el mundo moderno
especialmente en un país tan vasto como
rusia mientras conmemoraba el
aniversario 71 del lanzamiento del
cosmonauta soviético yuri gagarín como
el primer hombre en el espacio dijo no
tener dudas de que logrará todos sus
objetivos en ucrania será inevitable
solo era cuestión de tiempo y lo que
hacemos que es ayudar a las personas
salvarlas del nazismo por un lado y por
otro tomar medidas para garantizar la
seguridad de la propia rusia putin
desestimó los informes de los civiles
muertos mucha calificó de falsas las
acusaciones en torno al uso de armas
químicas y dijo que continuará
cooperando con otros países bajo las
nuevas condiciones que imponen las
sanciones occidentales
gracias por invitarnos a participar
definitivamente aceptaremos su propuesta
y le ofreceremos opciones interesantes
rusia construirá con belarús un satélite
de alta precisión motores de plasma para
naves espaciales y finalizará el
cosmódromo de boston